[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact in the deep cold
waters of the North Atlantic swims what
is probably the oldest fish in the world
not much is known about the mysterious
Greenland shark for one thing fishermen
avoid them because their flesh is toxic
as food additionally they avoid humans
there's no record of a Greenland shark
ever attacking a person this is partly
because they hang out in the deepest
parts of the ocean one shark was
discovered swimming over 5000 feet deep
however one thing researchers have
learned is that these sharks live a very
long time using radiocarbon dating
scientists tested the ages of 28
Greenland sharks they captured while
their dating methods have a wide margin
of error they estimate the Sharks may
live up to five centuries even our most
conservative figures estimate the Sharks
live at least 300 years in fact
Greenland sharks that can grow up to 24
feet in length age so slowly experts
believe they don't even reach maturity
for mating until they're a hundred and
fifty years old one reason they may live
so long is they move very slowly
swimming an average speed of one mile an
hour you know the Bible says it's also
true with people if we would slow down a
little bit we might live longer stay
with us friends we're going to learn
more on this edition of Bible answers
live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 phone call in
North America 800 for six three seven
two nine seven and we are streaming on
satellite on the Internet you can be
watching Bible answers live right now if
you tuned in to either the amazing facts
Facebook page or the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page and if you do you'll see
I'll bundled up in a warm a sweatshirt
because it's snowing in California which
is why Pastor Ross isn't here he's
actually snowed in but we're gonna start
the program with a word of Prayer and
trust that God is gonna draw us closer
to him father in heaven thank you so
much for the gift of your word and we
pray once again you will bring the
Blessed Book alive as we search to
better understand your will and what is
truth that truth that sets us free we
pray in Jesus name Amen
well I was fascinated to read about
these sharks he's Greenland sharks that
lives such long lives you know someone
wrote that theoretically that means that
there was one of these sharks alive when
William Shakespeare was still writing
and certainly there were Greenland
sharks
found when George Washington was
president that are still swimming today
just think about that pretty amazing if
you ever do any research online and you
look at them you see they move very
slowly then they're not at all
aggressive mostly scavengers they eat
things that die in sync
there's so little oxygen and the water
so cold they just age very very slowly
now they might be called the oldest
animal in the world but there are
actually clams that are older than these
sharks but these are the probably the
oldest moving creatures that God has
ever made and as I mentioned there might
be a connection between their taking it
easy and living so long you know the
Bible says that God wants us to avoid
stress over and over jesus said do not
be afraid do not be anxious do not worry
someone said there's 365 examples in the
Bible of Christ saying fear not and he
knows our bodies need physical rest to
help - you know decompress from the
stresses of life there was one time when
Jesus was so busy preaching and teaching
he fell asleep in a boat on another
occasion in mark 631 he said to the
disciples come aside by yourself to a
deserted or wilderness place and rest
awhile for there were many coming and
going they didn't even have time to eat
again that's mark 631 God knows we need
rest in fact jesus said come unto me in
Matthew chapter 11 all you who are weary
and heavy laden and I will give you rest
and that is one of the reasons that God
in His law set aside a day every week
where he commands us put aside our
regular work and rest we live a little
longer we have a free offer tonight that
talks about that and it's a book called
why God said remember we'll send it to
you for free you'll be blessed by it
this is a classic written by Joe Cruz
and it's a free sermon book why God said
remember if you would like a copy of the
book and you can call right now free
phone call free
no one's gonna harass you they're not
gonna put you on a list
try and sell you tires for your car
anything if you just call and you want
the book they'll give you the book
here's the number 808 three five six
seven
four seven that's 808 three five six
seven four seven that's a different
number for the free offer then the
number that comes to the studio which is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven and you can also go to the
amazing facts website and if you search
why God said remember you can download a
free PDF of that book and read it right
now all right with that we're gonna get
to our phones and talking with our first
caller tonight Holly calling from
Birmingham Alabama thank you for your
patience Holly you're on the air okay we
listen to you on a larger radio in
Birmingham Alabama well praise the Lord
I'm glad to hear that you've recorded
with some PDFs I mean some you know
public service announcement so anyway
we're thankful for your ministry I have
a question tonight about the Galatians
one eight six through nine focusing on
eight through nine so it says I marvel
that you're so soon removed from him
that called you into the grace of Christ
unto another gospel which is not another
but there be some that trouble you and
would pervert the gospel of Christ but
though we or another angel from heaven
preach any other gospel unto you than
that which we have preached unto you let
him be accursed
as we said before so say I now again if
any man preach any other gospel unto you
than that you have received let him be
accursed and I found the other two
scriptures that go with that second John
1:10 and that one says yeah if there
come any unto you and bring not this
doctrine receive him not into your house
neither bid him Godspeed and then of
course the final one is Romans 16:17
and that one says now defeats you
brethren mark them that cause divisions
and offences contrary to the doctrine
which you have learned and avoid them so
I say all that to ask I have some that
have come in and out of my life who have
led into things such as peacekeeping or
other you know kind of offshoot things
and now I've kind of come back into a
more stable truth of the gospel and
gotten away from those things right
because they were pre
that you had to be saved by those things
so how do I treat now that I still have
to converse with these people that back
and forth in church that's a great
question you know at let's just break
this down a little bit the Bible is
pretty clear someone's preaching the
wrong gospel let them be a curse well
what if a person understands all the
gospel but there's one component they
don't understand you know the seven
trumpets or the 144,000 or they might
you know they might be off on some issue
I think most of us would agree we
probably don't all have perfect
understanding of the Bible so there's
going to be areas where we're gonna
disagree on small things we shouldn't
shun everybody from our lives that may
have a different point of view on some
things but if a person is really
believing a different teaching on
salvation which is what Paul is talking
about in Galatians yeah the Jews were
telling the Gentile Christians they were
going to be lost unless they kept all of
these feasts and ceremonies and in some
of the Levitical law and he said you
know that's not the gospel you've heard
and let them be a curse if they're going
back to that and so if someone is
teaching a deviant gospel John and Paul
in the two verses you cited says you
know don't give them space in your life
it doesn't mean you're rude to them it
just they shouldn't be in a position
where you let them manipulate you and
don't send them on their way I wouldn't
you don't give them an offering and
support their ministry because you're
basically empowering them to confuse
other people so you know be loving that
this is how Jesus was Jesus talked to
people that had lots of
misunderstandings and he I mean how do
you reach someone that's confused except
you teach him so Jesus spent a lot of
time working with people that were
theologically mixed up even his
disciples did not understand the nature
of his first coming so I don't think
God's wanting us to alienate everybody
that disagrees with us but if someone is
entrenched in a false gospel and they're
trying to share it with you and
everybody else
you know you might labor with them once
or twice to try and reason if you're not
getting anywhere I cut them off and so
they don't drag you down yeah I
literally sometimes I'm supposed to give
them a
and say hey brother and you know see you
next time I hope I just wonder so I'm
reserved I wonder Lord teach me what I
need to know about how to do you know
clearly there's a line between trying to
guide us um someone that has a different
understanding and letting a person who
is theologically polluted pollute others
you have to pray the Holy Spirit's gonna
have give you that discernment because
I've asked that question many times you
know at what point do you say this
person is too far gone and I'm casting
my pearls before swine and I just need
to work with people that are still open
yeah I have to deal with that all the
time as a pastor because you know folks
come in and they they want to lead the
sheep astray and we want to reach them
but we don't want them hurting other
people with their teachings yeah this is
a very dangerous I mean yeah well good
question Holly I appreciate that
you know I offer you a sermon book I
don't really have one on specifically
that well I do have a book called how do
you know the will of God and you might
find that to be a blessing if you call
the resource line 808 three five six
seven four seven we'll send you a free
copy of how do you know the will of God
and there's some answers to what we
discussed in there thank you again with
that we're going to talk to Chris in
Florida Chris you're on the air with
Bible answers live
yes pastor Doug thank you um good
evening evening and my question is from
the Book of Amos Amos chapter eight they
start about in diverse nine when it
talks about prediction of punishment
darkness and mourning and and actually
in verse 11 when it talks about famine
and drought of the world of God yes when
is this going to happen let me read this
for our friends that are listening we've
got a lot of listeners driving down the
road listening on satellite and they
don't have their Bibles open so in Amos
chapter eight you start with verse 11
and says behold the days are coming says
the Lord God that I'll send a famine on
the land not a famine of bread or a
thirst for water but of hearing the
words of the Lord and they'll wander
from sea to sea and from north to east
and run to and fro seeking the word of
the Lord but shall not find it
well we know that there was a big famine
for the Word of God during the Dark Ages
they actually took the Word of God away
from people they put it in Latin they
chained Bibles in churches and you read
the story of Martin Luther and he was a
priest for several years before he laid
his eyes on a whole Bible and because
the word is a lamp to our feet when you
take away the Word of God you have a
spiritual famine and you have darkness
that's why that was called the dark ages
but I believe once again you can have a
famine for the Word of God where people
have Bibles in every home so if people
have Bibles in their home but they're
not reading the Bible or they don't
understand the Bible
it's a it's another kind of famine it's
like a goat
how do their hearts yeah and that can
even happen in our day and age I I've
seen a lot of biblical illiteracy even
among Christians you and I know people
there maybe in church every week but
they never read their Bibles and they
seldom pray and they've got very strange
ideas because they let the culture in
Hollywood explain the Bible to them so
there's a famine for the power of the
word that really gives us transformation
God's Word changes us when we read the
real thing not encourage everybody
listening I don't just listen to pastors
the theme of this program is to get
people to read their Bibles for
themselves and there is the power of the
word that will change us you know Chris
I have a free book I'd be happy to share
with you it's on the Bible it's called
the ultimate resource anyone if you like
a special gift book that talks about the
importance and the power of the word of
God we'll send you a copy of the book
it's called the ultimate resource it's a
sermon book here's the number eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven by the way if you if you have a
special need for prayer and you'd like
to talk to one of our online purch
aplans you can call this number they'll
be happy to pray with you as well eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven thank you Chris
want to know God's plan for our world
and solutions for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides
encouraging bible-based answers to
questions on healthier relationships
when Jesus will return and much more
refer to once while you read our brand
new prophecy encounters DVD series makes
the perfect companion set order your
study guides and DVDs today by visiting
AAF bookstore comm or by calling 805
three eight seven two seven five moving
on we're gonna talk to Sandy is calling
from Illinois sandy you're on the air
with Bible answers live hi Pastor Dave
I'm struggle with apparent dichotomies
and I'm not trying to be controversial
I'm trying to rightly divide the word of
truth because I always pray and invite
the Holy Ghost first but I'm trying to
understand and doing what you just
suggested you know praying and reading
for myself I'm finding wonderful things
but this is one that's got me perplexed
it's a King James Version and it's Jared
chapter one it's referencing verse
thirteen you know they were the eldest
son passed the sons and daughters of job
and they were eating okay and it's verse
15 says and the sabaeans
fell upon them and took them away and
then yay they fling the servants with
the edge of the sword the billing to go
down day 18 at references verse 13 again
but verse 19 said and behold there came
a great wind from the wilderness and
smote the four corners of the house and
it fell upon the young men and they were
all dead so I'm a little bit not
understanding yet well first of all the
day that job got this
blitzkrieg of bad news it says there was
a day so it happened to be a day when
all of his children were gathered in the
house of the oldest brother having a
feast it may have been one of their
birthdays and this is when all this
happened then a messenger comes to job
and he says first of all one messenger
comes all the Ox were plowing and the
donkeys feeding beside them the sabaeans
raided them and took him away so he's
lost and they killed the servants so
he's lost some property and then it says
while he's still speaking another
messenger comes from another part of his
ranch he's got an enormous piece of
property
and since the fire of God fell from
heaven lightning a lightning storm has
burned up the sheep and the servants and
consumed them and I alone am escaped and
while he's still speaking another one
comes and says Chaldeans formed three
bands raided the camels took them away
killed the servants and I alone on him
escaped and then one says your sons and
daughters were eating and drinking wine
in the oldest brother's house that's
referencing what was happening that same
day and a great wind a tornado came and
killed the young people okay thanks a
lot I appreciate your question and
talking next with Denis calling from
Wisconsin
Denis you're on the air with Bible
answers live welcome I'm passive talking
bastard
we're doesn't say in the Bible that the
Holy Spirit comes upon someone that's
not very holy with it with a evil spirit
and go out witness to people in a
community where they don't watch it -
until God says nothing and get arrested
for your sins against God and our
government you're saying where in the
bible does it say that
yeah well there's there's a place in the
Bible where it tells us that evil
spirits can be driven away by God's
Spirit when King Saul was being troubled
by evil spirits then you know David
would play his harp and the Spirit of
the Lord would drive away the the evil
spirits same thing happened when Christ
many times cast out evil spirits you can
read in mark chapter 5 a man was filled
with a Legion of evil spirits and then
he came to Jesus and Jesus cast out this
Allegiant which you know there are
thousands of spirits that were
possessing this man and he was filled
with God's Spirit and Jesus even sent
him out teaching and preaching the good
news immediately after he was healed now
when you go out teaching and preaching
Christ said if they've hated me don't be
surprised if they hate you if they
persecute me they'll probably persecute
you and so even when a person has the
Holy Spirit if they're out doing the
work of the Lord they may be persecuted
you want to do it with love and
Diplomacy intact but yeah if you're
sharing the truth Jesus said they hated
all the false prophets
or they hated all the true prophets that
were before you don't be surprised if
you get persecuted and thank you for
your question Dennis and we've had
several lined up so we're gonna move on
talk to Richard calling from Richland no
sorry Joseph in Richland Washington
Joseph you're on the air Joseph Joseph
in Washington you may have your mute on
Joseph and Richland Washington going
once
oh can you hear me I hear you now and
your question okay so I have a two
questions if possible short ones my
first question was is it okay for as
Christians and biblically to eat certain
foods that have a little bit of alcohol
like vinegar or soy sauce or like Manila
extract yeah you know if a person is
cooking with a little bit of alcohol in
it I I want to condemn a person for that
one reason is alcohol evaporates it's
70° and so if you're cooking with wine
by the time it gets your plate though
alcohol has gone out of it because it
just evaporates almost instantly it's
like you put rubbing alcohol on your
hands and you know it dries right away I
don't see that there's any moral dilemma
for a Christian to have alcohol in their
cooking now if you know if you're
dousing your salad with wine alcohol I'm
getting drunk on it then I'd say well
that's a different story
but you know for a person to use it with
flavor and it usually evaporates by the
time he goes to your mouth one other
question is for my fiancee she was
wondering is it okay to wear small
amounts of makeup just kind of make
yourself look natural but kind of cover
your blemishes and things like that yeah
you know then this now I can't give you
a scripture on this if I give you
scriptures the only scripture I can
really give you is it says that well let
me see there are a couple scriptures
there is a place where it talks about
the daughters of Israel in Isaiah
chapter 3 I think let me see if I can
find that for you real quick
talks about the daughters of Israel who
were proud and it talks about their
jewelry I don't know that it talks about
makeup per se I think it makes there you
go I you know that's what I was
wondering and then of course it says
Jezebel painted her face and
and the she got thrown out of window
which didn't end well but you know I
think the principle is Christians ought
to be as natural as possible we ought to
look healthy if a person is using makeup
so that they they start looking like you
know a clown and you know I don't mean
to be disrespectful to anybody but I
think we all know that you know when you
start using a lot of unnatural colors
and stuff it can look it's just
unnatural I would think that if you can
improve your appearance naturally or
cosmetically be a better witness and
great my wife wears a little bit
sometimes but she never wears enough
where a person can even tell because so
they look natural like a Christian
should yeah I just say if a lady's being
convicted about that and hey follow the
Holy Spirit usually if you got the Holy
Spirit and a mirror you'll know if
you're if you're acting like Jesus you
know sometimes a young lady will say
well I'm wondering if this dress is
looking too sexually provocative well
look in the mirror you know in and if
you're trying to look sexy in your
clothes that may not be what a Christian
woman is after because Jesus said a man
should not be looking and lusting in his
heart certainly a Christian woman would
not want a dress in a way to entice a
man to look in lust right right so this
is one thing about Christians should be
neat and clean and attractive the other
is we should not be unnatural or
immodest okay hey you know I've got a
book on it I can send you a free copy
for you or your you say your girlfriend
or wife is tit yeah yeah there you go
it's it's a book called jewelry how much
is too much
and in that book I talk about makeup
okay all right so you can get that free
book matter of fact we have two books
we've got a great book by Joe Cruz and
it's called colorful cosmetics and
jewelry and my book is called jewelry
how much is too much we get that
question a lot so we wrote these books
800 here's the number 808 three five six
seven four seven you tell the operators
I want the amazing facts book or books
on makeup and jewelry we'll send them to
you for free and we do all this for free
because we just believe that God will
supply us to keep supplying you all
right talking next with let me see here
net is calling from Charlotte North
Carolina now you're on the air with
Bible answers live I'd love your
ministry thank you for calling I'll make
my sob story short my wife can't affair
with someone I found out without any
drama I told her about it said I felt
sorry for her but she said she wanted to
sue for divorce the divorce became final
and she married the guy so I'm wondering
what woman if any I can biblically marry
well there Jesus said there are two or
three grounds for biblical divorce one
would be if a person if you're married
to someone and they violate the marriage
vows by fornication jesus said and
sounds like that's the criteria you're
describing I'm trusting you were
faithful during that time yeah I would I
would plead with you just from my
experience in life net don't do anything
quickly so often people get lonely
they're hurting they marry very quickly
after a divorce and the second marriages
often have a higher rate of failure than
first marriages because people are
rushing into something
take your time pray if you do find
someone you're dating date for a while
and make sure that there's that
spiritual compatibility I have a book I
can send you that talks about that and
we'll send you a free copy it's a great
book this is a real book friends it's
not just a sermon book it's called
marriage divorce and remarriage a lot of
people struggle with those questions
good for even happily married people to
read this book marriage divorce and
remarriage it talks about how to avoid
having a divorce or an affair if a
person how you can even restore
marriages where there's been some
unfaithfulness if you'd like a free copy
of that book now this is one you cannot
download you need to call the number if
you want to copy the book marriage
divorce and remarriage and I did a lot
of research
from the Bible and other good scholars
and writing this here is the number
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven tell the operators you're
listening to amazing facts they know as
well and you'd like to request a copy of
the book marriage divorce and remarriage
in just a moment we're gonna take a
break I could take a caller but I'd have
to cut you off before I could answer
your question so stand by those who are
online I see your names here Chris and
Kevin and Paul and Andrew and others and
we'll get to your question in just a
moment before we go to our halftime
break I just want to remind everybody
that we thank you for keeping amazing
facts in your prayers this is a ministry
sustained by prayer and entirely by the
support of the people and if you want to
help us keep on the radio just go to
amazing facts be right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore com or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five DT no amazing fax has a free Bible
school that you can do from the comfort
of your own home
it includes twenty seven beautifully
illustrated study lessons to aid in your
study of God's words sign up today for
this free Bible study course by calling
184 257,000 that's one eight four four
two one five seven thousand for over
fifty years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals
like you if you've been blessed by
amazing facts would you please consider
partnering with us to reach others with
a Bible truth your financial support
today will help keep programs like this
on the air
so the blessings you've received can be
shared with others every Bible question
you have answered moves you one step
closer to the fullness of God's will for
your life so what are you waiting for
get the answers you need for a fuller
richer more confident life you're
listening to Bible answers live this
broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
you are on the air with Bible answers
live
hello pastor Doug hi so I I love I love
scripture and I love researching and
looking into it and when I discovered
amazing facts I was I fell in love with
it because you you preach very very
plain and easy to understand and I love
that thank you and so one of the things
that I do is actually I minister to
atheists and I ran into something the
other day that kind of stumped me
and I believe that I should have the
reason for my faith and it was basically
a failed prophecy in sakura zechariah 14
12 through 19 and if you could read that
and kind of explain or kind of give me
an answer for that because i really was
stumped alright well andrew i want to
tell you upfront because we try to
budget three minutes for our answers so
we get as many as possible I will not be
able to read all of that and dissect it
I can take the first part of it if you'd
like just because it's it's a long
passage and there's it's a long answer
but for one thing Zechariah let me just
maybe say a word about how Bible
prophecy works Bible prophecies
including Zechariah there are four main
apocalyptic prophets in the Bible these
prophets often saw in dreams and visions
and symbols John and revelation Ezekiel
Daniel and Zechariah they had dreams and
they often saw things and symbols you
know Zechariah sees these lamp stands
and these olive trees and these women
flying with stork wings and and you need
to apply the Bible symbols what they
represent to these prophecies these
prophecies are not given in
chronological order so you can't read
verse 14 verse 12 through 19 and say
this all happened sequentially now just
take verse 12 for instance Zechariah
14:12 this will be the plague wherewith
the Lord will smite the people that have
fought against Jerusalem their flesh
will consume away while they stand on
their feet their eyes will consume away
in their holes their tongue will consume
away in their mouths what is he talking
about if you go to Revelation chapter 20
talks about when the enemies of God's
people Gog and Magog attack the New
Jerusalem and fire comes down from God
out of heaven and devoured this
prophecies and failed this prophecy is
still a future prophecy and that would
be true of some of the others that you
find here in Zechariah chapter 14 you
know and and I won't pretend that I
understand although Zechariah 14 verse
16 and 14 also apply to that same time
period it talks about it shall be that
whosoever will not
of all the families of the earth into
Jerusalem to worship the king the Lord
of Hosts even upon them shall be no rain
and I think there's some spiritual
applications here it's basically saying
that you know those who do not serve the
Lord in the last days they dry up and
die going into Egypt that was a symbol
of slavery you know there's a lot there
I wish I could give you more information
on that but though that's a broad
passage of Scripture maybe you can call
me with part two to your question
another time and we'll we'll do another
segment of Zechariah 14 thank you Andrew
hope you got something out of that deep
within the pages of the Bible stories of
great heroes heroes of great deeds great
love and great sacrifice but behind them
is another hero hidden in plain sight
amid the shadows he was there from the
beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible get your copy today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767 then we are that's why
Jesus came thank you so much and I'm
sure that she she was playing an old and
a lot of times she was asking the Lord
to forgive her so well if she if the
Lord asked her for forgiveness he
promises when we repent if we pray
sincerely he forgives us oh great thank
you so much I'm I'm just hoping to see
her again when the Lord comes
amen well that's nessam prayer we hope
we can see our loved ones again in the
kingdom Thank You Elizabeth and you be a
faithful witness in the meantime thank
you so much you're welcome thank you so
much Douglas okay
got much all right talking next with
Paul calling from Columbus Ohio Paul
you're on the air with vinyl answers
live hey thank you um I had a question
about second Kings 19 where as they
prophesized about the necklace fall
right before hitting his army in verse
29 he prophesized specifically to
Hezekiah and 29 and 30 and 31 seemed 30
and 31 seemed to make sense
and match up with Revelation but 29 I
don't quite understand what he says this
year you will eat what grows by itself
in the second year which Springs from
that but in the third year or so and
weep plant vineyards and eat their food
Tiffany saw coming yeah I think so the
this is talking about a time when the
Syrian army had come down from North
they had destroyed Israel they carried
away the is the northern tribes as
captive then they went into Judah now
keep in mind friends the Kingdom of
Israel was divided in two parts at this
point the ten tribes in the north there
was a civil war they split off their
capital was Samaria
they'd been conquered by the Assyrians
Judah which is where we get the word Jew
the southern kingdom capital in
Jerusalem Hezekiah was the king king of
Assyria his general Tsin Sennacherib and
the general rep Chaka they came and
insulted and they said we're gonna
conquer you just like the other kingdoms
and and God delivered Hezekiah cuz he
and Isaiah and the people prayed now the
Assyrians had surrounded Jerusalem they
destroyed the crops they they devoured
everything like grasshoppers and Isiah
was saying look you haven't had time to
plant this year so you're gonna have to
eat what grows volunteer and that'll
also probably happen the second year but
the third year the Assyrians are gonna
be subdued so you don't have to be
afraid about going out into the fields
and farming and planting you're gonna
have peace so Isaiah was saying they
couldn't leave the cities they couldn't
leave the strongholds because the
Assyrians were raiding the country it's
like the times of Gideon you read about
Gideon's hiding why he's threshing wheat
because the Moabites were raiding the
country
so Isaiah is saying you're gonna have
peace again the Assyrians are gonna be
driven out of the land and that God
would give them complete freedom you'd
have to eat things that grew by
themselves you won't have time to sow
unto harvest the 1st and 2nd year but
the 3rd year you will sow and reap and
you'll be peaceful times again thank you
that helps all right hey thank you I I
love that story me too appreciate your
question Paul
all right talking next with oh I think
Tony's calling from Boston Massachusetts
or no I think I pressed Dale in Mexico
Dale a New Mexico you're on how are you
sir thank you for taking my call thanks
for calling thank you sir I have a
question I was reading I'm a baby
Christian I was reading in the Bible
about the Centurion soldier uh-huh who
came to Jesus and he talked about his
servant a good servant and Jesus said
you hear that man I have not heard such
great faith in all of Jerusalem ok
that's one question second question I
would like to know is this the same
soldier who was at the cross when Jesus
passed away and since surely this man is
a righteous man you know it's very
interesting in the Bible there are four
or five Centurions that are mentioned
Centurions were they were the Roman
soldiers that had worked their way up
because they were chosen by their own
men as men of integrity there were
leaders they didn't by their office they
really had to be the workers all the
Centurions mentioned in the Bible
Centurion had a hundred soldiers under
that's very good century yeah yeah they
were good men you had one named Julius
who took care of the Apostle Paul and
he's always spoken of well you have the
man that had faith that jesus healed
then you've got Cornelius in Acts
chapter 10 and then you've got the one
at the cross so he says surely this is
son of God you know we can't really
build a strong case that that the one at
the cross was the same one where jesus
healed a servant the one where Christ
heals a servant he's not named the one
of the Cross it doesn't give us his name
either probably neither of those were
Cornelius because Cornelius lived down
by the Seacoast in a town called
Caesarea
but you know it could have been the same
one whose servant was healed I want to
put too much into that because the
Romans had thousands and thousands of
soldiers in Jerusalem there were many
many Centurions all I could do is
speculate it'd be fun to get to heaven
and find out was it the same guy exactly
and I just have one more question sir
yeah I'm still kind of struggling with
my past and every once in a while it
comes up and I fall and it's like you
know I know that's not what my God has
for me I would like something to help me
you know I pretty all the time and you
know it's like you know like it sounds
like I'm getting attacked you know even
more but I understand that you know you
must be doing something right if you're
being attacked you know the state you
know as long as we're in this life we
are gonna battle with temptation I do
have something I'd like to send you it's
free it's a book I wrote called
tips for resisting temptation these are
twelve Bible principles that it really
gives you ammunition to for one thing
avoid temptation and the other thing
when it does come and it will come to
help you be victorious because God can
help you be successful and overcome past
histories and patterns so if you want
I'll send you a free copy and the the
number you call to get that is one eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven that's eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven Dale you can
also go to the amazing facts website
type in tips for resisting temptation at
Doug Batchelor and you can download a
copy of it for free we try to get the
truth out there and make it as easy for
people as we can I think you can even
type into YouTube Doug Batchelor
temptation and you will have see a
sermon that I did on that subject or
might even be a couple of them but I
hope that helps a little Dale and I used
to live in New Mexico
all right we're talking next now Tony
calling from Boston sorry I I called
your name up by accident Tony you're on
the air now hi pastor Doug how are you
good thank you for calling and waiting
yeah thank you for taking my call
I I had a question on
when we're reading in Revelation were
reading about the new holy the holy
Jerusalem coming down from heaven I was
also reading in Ezekiel in chapter 48 on
verses 30 to 35 and I just wanted your
interpretation you know is there any
correlation there do you think with the
gates when it describes the three gates
on each side because in Revelation it
just simply says they're like a pearl
yeah you know a lot of what you find in
Revelation is drawn from Ezekiel's
vision there's a lot of overlap it talks
about the gates for Zebulon and Simeon
well the New Jerusalem says that you've
got the names of the twelve tribes in
the gates and the names the apostles and
the Foundation's
and in Ezekiel he says the Tree of Life
or he says that the trees are by the
river and their leaves are for medicine
in Revelation that says the leaves of
the tree of life are for the healing of
the nation's
a lot of parallels that you find here
Ezekiel gives a little more detail about
the river that flows from the throne of
God is going to irrigate the new earth
and it says everywhere the river flows
everything lives keep in mind in
Jerusalem to the river that flows out of
the Kidron down to the Jordan runs into
the Dead Sea and nothing lives
so when Ezekiel said everything where
this river flows is going to live was a
new concept for them because they had a
whole sea that was dead the Jordan River
didn't have a lot of fish and life in it
at that time so when you're asking
specifically about the gates now it does
say in Revelation that each of the gates
was made of a pearl and of course people
think no doesn't a pearl come from an
oyster and those must be very big oyster
's in heaven well I think that you know
God it's no problem for him to make a
pearl without an oyster I mean even men
make artificial pearls today so God
knows how to make a be big beautiful
pearl I don't think he needs an oyster
to do it God doesn't need a mother to
make a man that's how he made Adam right
and the and the the last part of it was
at the very end it says the name of the
city was the Lord is there
you know and then when you look in
Revelation it just talks about holy
Jerusalem so you know some people call
it the New Jerusalem but is it actually
called the New Jerusalem well you know
what I think Ezekiel is doing is the
very end of Revelation it says God
Himself will be with them and be their
God and they will see his face
so Ezekiel is emphasizing the Lord is
there now when Solomon dedicated the
earthly temple he said you know there's
no temple on earth that can house you
but in the new earth says God Himself
will be with them and dwell with him and
so he's moving the capital of the
universe to our planet and so I think
this is what Ezekiel saying I don't
think he's saying that the name that's
gonna be you know and chiseled above the
city is the Lord is there I think it's a
title for what the city will be known
for God dwells in this city it's kind of
like one of the titles for Jesus is God
with them Emmanuel God with them right
right great that's a wonderful subject
by the way we have a study guide that
talks about heaven is it for real it's a
sermon book I think it's very inspiring
if you or anybody Tony wants to copy
that book heaven is it for real we'll
send you a free copy 800 835 operators
are there right now just pick up the
phone and call them what have you got to
lose except some inspiration about
heaven eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and they'll send
that to you are you gonna keep moving
along here talking to is it Borrego
thank you for calling your question I'm
a courier and I'm a Christian what is
the mark of the beast is I think what we
have written down here and I think I
heard you say that yeah that's a big
study yeah but I'll tell you very
quickly that everyone knows in
Revelation it says in chapter 13 that
there's going to be a group that will
worship the Beast and His image and they
will have a mark in the right hand or in
the forehead and those who are saved
have the seal of God in their forehead
in the forehead in the Bible is symbolic
not everybody in the last days is going
to be going around with a tattoo or a
barcode or a computer chip injected in
there for
or in their hand in Deuteronomy chapter
6 it talks about we need the law of God
in our hearts and Moses said write these
Commandments on the posts of your house
talk of them when you lay down when you
rise up they should be frontlets between
your eyes and it should be a sign on
your hand on your hand in your forehead
those that do not have the law of God in
their hand that means your actions in
your forehead your thoughts they will
have the mark of the beast now we
remember that when Cain would not
worship the way God told them to he
killed his brother he got upset and God
put a mark on Cain and then you go to
Revelation I'm sorry you go to Daniel
chapter 3 Nebuchadnezzar
persecuted those who would not bow down
and worship His image they refused to
break the law of God so in the last day
is this beast power this conglomerate
of political religious power in the last
days is going to compel people to
worship a certain way and if they refuse
to worship that way that requires them
to break the law of God they will be
persecuted they'll have the seal of God
those who worship the laws of the Beast
will have the mark of the beast that's
it's that simple we have a lesson we'll
send you and anybody else who would like
a copy of that and the lesson is called
the mark of the beast if you'd like that
lesson on the mark of the beast then
call 808 three five six seven four seven
we'll be happy to send Matt to find out
what the critics are raving about top
scholars and theologians from around the
country come together to reveal the
hidden history of the book of Revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects this 95 minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
Revelation like never before revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today visit iTunes or AF bookstore calm
all right
and of course we're streaming right now
on Facebook on the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page and the amazing facts
Facebook page if you wanted to watch as
well as listen alright let's see here
we're going to talk Jeanne has a
question from Missouri we've got about
three minutes left okay pastor Doug
thanks for taking my call I understand I
know that as Christians were not to take
our brother to court but what if you've
been injured by a corporation by their
due to their negligence what about that
well is that the same thing no I don't
think it is the same thing most of what
Jesus taught were what you would call
social laws for example jesus said if
someone hits you on one side of the face
offer them the other that's talking
about an interpersonal relationship
governments cannot operate that way a
government cannot say to a criminal go
ahead and shoot this person then we're
gonna let you shoot that person civil
law is an eye for an eye a government
must be severe it Paul says the same
thing jesus said in our relationships if
someone says can you carry my stuff one
mile say now I'm going to carry it too
he wants us to be loving patient
merciful forgiving if a corporation
breaks a law that causes injury
according to the laws of the Bible they
are responsible to recompense even in
the law of Moses if somebody caused
injury or loss if if for example if a
person had an oxen and the oxen had a
bad habit of charging and goring people
and you knew that and you didn't keep
your oxen tied up or cooped up and
they've gored your neighbor Moses said
you are responsible for the life of your
neighbor you need to make restitution to
his family and those were those were
civil laws so I think what you're asking
me about is a civil law you would not
want to be in a frivolous lawsuit
everyone's very litigious these days and
sue for nothing keep in mind if you get
involved in a lawsuit you have to ask
God is it worth it because it's very
emotionally draining it takes a lot of
time and you have to just make sure the
devil isn't distracting you but it may
be your only course sometimes a lawyer
can help you settle things and adjust
and the quick manner and so that would
be my advice you know I think in our
relationships we can be forgiving when
it comes to a civil matter there are
laws that are there to protect people
all right well thank you that's a big
help I appreciate it all right hey thank
you very much well pray God gives you
wisdom I might have time for let's see
here one more all right
Gayle is calling from New Jersey Gayle
you're on the air with Bible answers
live it even pastor Doug I've been
following your ministry forever and I'm
so happy to have the opportunity to
speak to you well thank you but I wanted
to say welcome I want to ask what I do
believe that we're living in the last
days and as a single female is it okay
to want to be married or just really
focus on Christ and return spreading
God's love that he's returning sometimes
I'm like so confused it's because I
don't want to be distracted by worldly
things well you know Paul talks about
that in 1st Corinthians 7 he said you
know the married person cares about the
things of their spouse the unmarried the
things of the Lord you probably read
those verses I've got to be very careful
as a pastor not to be telling couples
whether they should marry or not you
know there's a verses that Jesus shares
in Matthew 24 speaking about the end of
time where he says woe to those that are
with child and nursing in that time for
there'll be great distress and some
parents have said you know we're so
close to the end we probably shouldn't
have children well I don't know no man
knows the day or the hour I know there
were families 80 years ago that said
Jesus coming is so close we shouldn't
have children well hey no he they could
have had grandchildren at this point so
people during World War two said the
atomic bomb the Lord's coming is so
close we better not have children I
think that we need to be very careful
about
saying that I don't know you pray and
ask for God's guidance and of course it
is possible for you to have a spouse and
you don't necessarily need to have
children you may work I know some
Christians got married and they decided
not to have children to work together in
winning souls you're just gonna have to
pray about that one I do have that book
Gayle where I talk about marriage
divorce and remarriage and I think it
also has some counsel in there even for
singles and we'll send you a free copy
808 three five six seven four seven if
you're interested in that that's once
again one eight hundred eighty three
five six seven four seven now friends it
probably would not be fair to our other
callers if you're standing by and we did
not get your call please forgive us give
us another chance but if I was Joshua I
would pray the Sun would stand still but
I can't do that
and we're gonna run out of time before I
can take your question before I do sign
off I want to thank you again for tuning
in keep in mind if you're listening to
this program someone just like you says
I'm blessed by this Bible teaching I
want to keep it on the air macing fax is
100% supported by individuals like you
that they just go online they click
where it says donate and they give a
little something to keep us on the air
every bit helps we'd love to hear from
you if you're blessed by the program go
to amazing facts dot o-r-g let us know
we'll study together again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named Rahm was violent they were
ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
see his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com journey back
through time to the center of the
universe discover how a perfect angel
transformed into Satan the arts villain
the birth of evil a rebellion in heaven
that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong find out what the
critics are raving about top scholars
and theologians from around the country
come together to reveal the hidden
history of the book of Revelation with
powerful reenactments and incredible
visual effects this 95 minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
Revelation like never before revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today
you